Noi siamo
per questa puntata avremmo potuto avere
come ospite una persona che sventola a
testa alta la bandiera dei diritti umani
dell'uguaglianza razziale del diritto
all'amore della rappresentazione di sé
ma di persone di quel tipo ne avete già
tre dadi all'inizio di questa
trasmissione no seduto a questo tavolo
Quindi abbiamo deciso di non giocare in
casa e cercare di metterci un pochino in
difficoltà esistono persone che
combattono per difendere ciò in cui
credono contro un mondo che non vuole
abbandonare il medioevo Ma c'è anche chi
lotta quotidianamente contro la scienza
e il buon senso per affermare la propria
verità contro ogni discriminazione e chi
siamo noi quindi per non prendere
appunti sulla capacità di dire la
propria qualunque costo e contro
qualunque logica umana dal dottor Franco
Kendy nome Franco Candy professione
ricercatore ufologo nella sua vita è
stato rapito due volte dagli alieni La
terza è stata inventata dal Media per
riconquistarlo Dai dai Scusate dai media
per ridicolizzarlo la sua sensazione è
quella di essere sparito per pochi
minuti Ma in realtà è scomparso per 24
consumatore ha parlato telepaticamente
con gli alieni nel 2007 ha visto i
cerchi di grano ad Argenta bagliori nel
buio è il film che più si avvicina al
suo rapimento curiosità il film è uscito
10 anni dopo il Terribile avvenimento
secondo lui noi umani siamo esperimenti
degli alieni Allora ragazzi io direi a
questo punto di metterci il nostro
vestito più professionale e far entrare
Franco Franco Come possiamo immaginare
ha subito un sacco di bullismo o
comunque mediatico cioè Certo certo
ma si mette un pochino un mirino sopra
la fronte Ora per una puntata legata
alla capacità di dire alla propria
contro tutto e contro tutti secondo me
lui è perfetto allora Franco Benvenuto
grazie mille grazie a tutti voi per
avermi invitato ma guarda È un piacere
Noi oggi facciamo una puntata proprio
legata alla capacità di dire la propria
nonostante tutto e tutti per due volte
tu hai subito una proprio rapimento
giusto e e poi da bambino mi si sono
avvicinati quei tre grigi piccoli un
metro circa che mi hanno avvicinato
quando ero piccolo per probabilmente per
studiarmi per prendermi dei campioni di
DNA eccetera eccetera
ricordi assolutamente Tra l'altro i miei
genitori mi hanno portato dallo
psicologo dallo psicologo mi ha chiesto
Ma tu come sono quelle quelle quei
personaggi che hai visto avevano la
testa ovale e gli occhi allungati
Insomma quello che l'immaginario diciamo
comune è proprio grigio comune che
adesso allora non si chiamavano grigi si
chiamavano semplicemente extraterrestre
extraterrestri nel 62 quando io stavo
per andare a scuola di lì a pochi giorni
perché è successo in settembre Questo
fatto mi si sono avvicinati di notte
questi questi questi entrando da dove si
trovava la casa la casa non in centro a
Milano una via di mezzo tra il centro e
la periferia ok Quindi loro sono
arrivati sono entrati li hai visti anche
entrare Sì la prima volta li ho visti
solo uscire sentivo dei passettini
Picco cioè quando cammino un bambino no
che magari non vuole fare rumore Allora
i piedi strisciano
ma lo percepivo e ho proprio visto una
sagoma all'inizio lo percepivo solo poi
dopo la sagoma l'ho vista proprio anche
la testa perché questo non solo mi è
venuto sopra a guardarmi se è appoggiato
col con le manine cioè manine si va per
dire le mani erano piccole maledite
erano lunghe cioè avevano solo tre dita
e un pollice tipo la mano di ET per
intendersi Ok mi sono girato in fretta e
ne ho visti altri due a quel punto mi
sono messo a piangere dalla paura quando
hanno sentito i miei genitori che
stavano arrivando nella mia cameretta
per capire che cosa stava succedendo
Loro sono scomparsi si è aperta l'aria e
sono andati fuori ma come se fosse una
dissolvenza No no aspetta ti spiego come
sono le cose Tu fai conto che fra me e
te adesso c'è l'aria ok
a un certo punto come se ci fosse una
tendina si apre fa un ovale e loro
passano in mezzo si crea un portale fra
me e te loro ci saltano dentro e il
portale già psichico cosa c'è dall'altra
parte non lo so io non ci sono mai
entrato in quel portale lì sicuramente
adesso ancora ci sono loro però di quel
portale lì dove porta Non lo so quante
volte è successo che sono venuti a
visitare una ventina di volte cos'è che
facevano cioè semplicemente Si
avvicinavano si avvicinavano E loro
parlavano con me solo che parlavano
senza aprire la bocca con
telepaticamente io non so se loro mi
sentissero però sono sicuro che loro
facevano di tutto per rendersi simpatici
amichevoli perché non mi hanno mai fatto
del male quindi venivano Come quasi
osservato visitare e basta torna
indietro di un pochino tutti noi quando
siamo nati che siamo in fasce che siamo
in culla entro la terza notte siamo
avvicinati sempre da questi esseri vini
qua Loro arrivano cosa fanno
comprendono qualche cosa che potrebbe
essere un campione per il vostro DNA
cioè un po' di saliva un po' un capello
un pelo qualcosa
Esatto fanno uno schedario poi dopo se
tu hai un DNA A loro compiacente così
con un DNA A loro compreso il gruppo
sanguigno Perché il gruppo sanguigno
della loro preferite dello zero domanda
come fai a sapere questa cosa del fatto
che vengono a visitare tutti quanti i
bambini nelle culle me l'hanno detto
Cioè tu conosci la finali cioè se loro
hanno una missione una finalità o non
non lo conosco però ti posso dire quello
che hanno fatto su di me lo stesso una
sera dell'8 dicembre del 1984 Io e altri
tre amici abbiamo deciso di andare a
casa di alcuni altri nostri amici che
abitano vicino a Radio telescopio la
croce del Nord a Medicina in provincia
di Bologna e il percorso che c'è fra
Argenta e medicina è tutta campagna e
abbiamo visto queste luci sull'acqua
verso la palude dalla quale noi dovevamo
passarci a fianco per poter andare
medicina man mano che ci stavamo
avvicinando queste luci diventavano
sempre più intense e sembravano dei
flash quando ci siamo avvicinati si è
librato in volo una sfera una sfera di
circa un metro di diametro girava
vorticosamente Flash da tutte le parti
quando abbiamo visto questa cosa qui
abbiamo pensato scappiamo siamo andati
via a tutta velocità quella che la
macchina ci dava E questa cosa sempre
sempre sopra di noi di fianco a noi
anche di dietro di noi
ci seguiva per quanto da lì dove abbiamo
visto la sfera fino a quando si è
fermata e tornate indietro Sono passati
circa 5 km e comunque la vedevate tutte
questa sfera cioè sì sì sì assolutamente
Ma infatti questa qui è la prima domanda
mi viene nel senso che c'è mai stato uno
di questi amici che ha detto Fermi C'ero
anch'io cioè Dove sono finiti questi
amici magari quando poi ti sei ritrovato
in situazioni dove gli scettici hanno
utilizzato dei tipi di attacchi elementi
molto forti i miei tre amici si sono
sempre rifiutati di fare questa
interviste qua perché non ci volevano
mettere la faccia non ci volevano
mettere le loro idee hanno passato paura
Quella sera lì perché adesso fino adesso
sono ancora molto dolce la cosa dopo
quando arriva arrivo alla fine lì è più
è più paurosa la cosa ok È un qualcosa
che vissuto solo tu quello che ci stai
per andare a raccontare o è sempre un
qualcosa che avete vissuto e sapevo
tutto Il rapimento oggettivo l'ho subito
io siamo arrivati a casa dei nostri
amici quelli di medicina i quali proprio
quella sera lì ci hanno raccontato che
avevano visto una cosa del genere una
sera o due prima Ti posso fare una
domanda indiscreta eravate lucidi Sì non
Cioè io non bevono con gli amici non
bevono non hanno mai bevuto neanche loro
quando siamo tornati indietro ci siamo
messi in cammino per tornare indietro
abbiamo passato questo paese qua che non
era illuminato
almeno a metà strada siamo incapati in
una cosa che lì ci ha fatto capire che
probabilmente la cosa stava per
risuccedere sembrava che fosse un
candelotto lacrimogeno nel mezzo della
strada che iniziava a spruzzare fumo
questo fumo qua era di colore verdastro
sembrava fosforescente in un attimo ha
riempito tutta la campagna Quando ci ha
avvolto il motore della macchina si è
spento le luci si sono spente siamo
rimasti lì Immobili nel mezzo della
strada se passavo un camion eravamo
morti abbiamo sentito un ronzio e sopra
le nostre teste si è ripresentata sempre
quella sera cosa è successo a quel punto
c'ha illuminato con un faro era
intensissimo questa luce il gesto che
abbiamo fatto è questo
siamo rimasti immobili fermi per una
decina di minuti o almeno dopo abbiamo
scoperto che era una decina meno di
minuti Però all'inizio pensavamo fosse
si trattasse di pochi secondi questi due
tre secondi che avevamo immaginato la
luce si è spenta e a questo punto la
sfera se ne è andata e portandosi via
anche tutta la nebbia ma questo fascio
di luce è inteso come rapimento cioè
quando tu parli di rapimento è quello è
stato il momento in cui probabilmente mi
hanno rapito io questo che vi sto per
raccontare l'ho scoperto nel 2015 quando
durante la puntata di mistero mi hanno
fatto fare anche una regressione
ipnotica E durante questa regressione
ipnotica io ho rivisto tutto quel tempo
che abbiamo perso Cioè mi hanno preso e
mi hanno trasportati hanno preso ehm
Non lo so però mi hanno preso e mi hanno
trasportato in un altro posto a contatto
ricordi come sei finito in quest'altro
posto assolutamente perché io quando mi
sono risvegliato perché ero praticamente
ho svenuto addormentato mi sono
risvegliato su un lettino mi hanno
immobilizzato Infatti io non ero capace
di muovermi ma immobilizzato in maniera
meccanica di tipo pollacci o cose Oppure
immobile cioè loro mi hanno praticamente
imparato poi mi hanno messo una cosa
sulla fronte che è più o meno quello che
succede Adesso con la era così Ah ok ok
metallica con tante lucine sopra e poi
all'altezza delle fegato sotto le
costole mi hanno iniettato una sostanza
che quando è entrata bruciava tantissimo
Da allora non mi ammalo più nè un
raffreddore
è importante loro mi hanno messo dentro
un qualche cosa che non mi ha più fatto
ammalare Scusami faccio sempre una
domanda indiscreta io visto che stiamo
venendo praticamente fuori da una
pandemia tu sei No vax Sì io non sono
stato vaccinato né vaccinato né
tamponato niente e non voglio farlo e
mai ammalato mai niente io sono sempre
stato benissimo Tu adesso Scusami quanti
anni hai Io ne ho 66 Quindi tu è 38 anni
38 anni che non ti ammali ok Quindi
arriva questo momento ehm dove vivendo
questa esperienza ti iniettano questo
liquido questo liquido poi e poi
finisce tutto sono ripiombato in un
sonno ipnotico probabilmente e mi sono
stato trasportato ancora sulla macchina
quando sono arrivato sulla macchina
sempre durante l'ipnosi ho visto che
altri tre erano ancora alla fermi Così a
un certo punto si è spenta la luce e gli
altri Si sono cominciati a muovere Io
già mi muovevo la sfera se n'è andata la
nebbia se n'è andata Descrivi questo
mondo alieno Comunque con una tecnologia
di un certo tipo però usano le siringhe
Eh volevo chiedere quello anch'io non
era una casalinga come quelle che ci
sono degli ospedali era una cosa lunga
che si allungava che è proprio come
quello che è successo in quel film
bagliori nel buio e loro hanno fatto il
film nel 93 però questa memoria Tu
comunque l'hai recuperata nel 2015 Sì sì
allora
c'è stata una seconda volta nel 2011 ero
appena da poco divorziato per cui vivevo
da solo in casa mia Avevo la sensazione
che di notte succedesse qualche cosa
sentivo dei rumori sentivo in cucina in
bagno qualche cosa sembra che ci fosse
qualcuno Questa è una due tre dieci sere
sentivo veramente dei passi in cucina mi
sono alzato da letto Ho preso anche il
telefono cellulare e me lo sono portato
con me sono andato a vedere in tutti i
posti anche in cucina ci sono le luci
non c'era nessuno a questo punto dico
vabbè Mi bevo un bicchiere di acqua sono
ero in cucina a un certo punto è
diventato tutto illuminato esattamente
come quella la sera della sfera mi sono
sentito
sollevare come sempre prelevassero dalle
spalle per tirarmi su in alto e sono
uscito di casa nonostante che era tutto
chiuso dall'interno mi sono risvegliato
in un altro posto Ero sopra un altro
lettino come quello di prima e io
muovevo semplicemente gli occhi a destra
e sinistra per vedere cosa stava
succedendo e di fianco a me c'erano
parecchi altri lettini forse un
centinaio Forse anche di più tante
persone di fianco a me
nella stessa situazione ma lì c'erano
alieni entravano due alieni alla volta
erano altissimi questi erano alti più di
due metri due metri e qualche cosa cioè
sono sempre dei grigi sono sempre dei
grigi ma sono quegli altri perché poi ci
stanno ma non sono bambini No no non
sono quelli piccoli non sono bambini
sono proprio alti così Sì grazie aliene
ce ne sono di di diverso tipo io ho
visto solo i Grigi quelli piccoli i
Grigi quelli alti ma i piccoli non sono
mmm della stessa razza di più grandi
sono quegli altri quelli alti ci sono
quelli alti e quelli bassi quelli alti
sono molto lunghi cioè molto sottili e
con le dita lunghissime braccia avevano
delle mani che erano più o meno lunghe
così cioè con tre dita e un pollice Ma
ti hanno iniettato una cosa sembrava
quasi che mi volessero fare un check up
di quello che mi avevano fatto nel 84
Questa consapevolezza Come fa ad esserci
Se tu nel secondo rapimento non avevi
coscienza del primo era la domanda
volevo fare però voglio dire Siccome io
so di avere subito qualche cosa ma non
ho su non non ricordavo di avere avuto
la la la lattina sapevo che comunque mi
avete mi avevano fatto qualche cosa però
questa volta la differenza è che tu hai
ricordato Non è stato un momento di luce
e poi sei tornato questa volta invece
per un motivo ricordate ricordate tranne
il trasporto a un certo punto è
diventato tutto bianco e io sono
ritornato indietro però non sono tornato
in casa Io sono stato un giorno quella
volta lì non 10 minuti Vivi da solo eh
sì vivo da solo avevo una compagna che
abitava in un'altra città questa
compagna era preoccupata per me perché
era tutto il giorno che provava a
chiamarmi ma io non rispondevo mai
Infatti il mio telefono era per terra
che ce l'aveva in mano quando mi hanno
sollevato è caduto per terra si è aperto
ti sei trovato che erano 24 ore dopo
quasi 24 ore dopo dove nello stesso
punto dove ho visto la sfera nell'84
in mezzo al nulla in mezzo al nulla io
ero scalzo c'era la brina per terra e a
giorno e notte notte
quasi alle 10:00 di sera e poi da quel
momento in poi non è più successo nulla
No non è più successo ognuno nulla
perché io ehm intanto ho comprato un
cane che se c'è qualche cosa a mio
avviso e non avevo proprio più
intenzione di farmi rapire Infatti i
miei amici hanno detto Guarda se tutti
compri un cane stai meglio perché questo
è un o un pastore tedesco
quali sono ad oggi le critiche che ti
vengono mosse quotidianamente Immagino
che ormai uno ci fa anche il callo da ti
inventi tutto sono cazzate te lo sei
immaginato noi leoni da tastiera che
quelli Ti aggrediscono Però io li blocco
tutti man mano che saltano fuori Penso
di averne bloccati dei milioni quasi
cioè adesso parte gli scherzi Comunque
ne ho bloccati parecchi di quelli che
partono subito con l'offesa ma l'offesa
di che tenore può essere ehm
di tutti dal [ __ ] dal deficiente
invece ci sono però dopo Tanti tempi
dopo tanto tempo immagino all'interno
del quale ti sei permesso anche secondo
me di costruire una corazza delle
critiche ad oggi fanno Magari ancora un
po' male c'è stato un'intervista che ho
me l'hanno fatta nel 2017 da un una
trasmissione Rai che mi ha presentato in
una maniera assolutamente diversa da
come sono io quella trasmissione lì era
imperniata su al terrapiattismo io non
non terrapiattista però siccome che ho
parlato molto su su internet di questa
cosa su Blog sono venuti a intervistarmi
sulla terra piatta poi dopo all'interno
di questo servizio loro erano
incuriositi anche sul fatto del
dell'ufologia e io in quel momento stavo
facendo dei cortometraggi per quello che
riguardava la mia vita ufologica hanno
guardato queste cose queste scene le
hanno riprese e le hanno mostrate come
se io avessi fatto la più grossa bufala
di questo mondo dicendo vedi quello è
nel momento in cui vengo anch'io sono
stato rapito ed è le riprese dalla mia
webcam intanto quelle lì erano delle
prove di registrazione tra l'altro anche
riuscite male lo hanno fatto vedere per
questo per questa trasmissione
televisiva e hanno detto loro La Bufala
non io non è vero che sono stato rapito
in quella cosa lì ma tutta questa tua
necessità di divulgare No cioè Qual è il
messaggio non abbiate paura perché tanto
Quando vengono non vi fanno mai del male
il il terrore che però quando dici
questa cosa perché la premessa di prima
è adesso ho preso un cane perché non
voglio più essere rapito voglio più
essere rapito Eh certo perché mi sono
anche un po' stancato di fare la cavia
per gli altri capito Prima parlavi di
relazioni Com'è che i tuoi partner hanno
vissuto o gli amici diciamo esterni a
quello che è il mondo dell'ufologia la
storia che ti stavo raccontando prima
che non mi hanno messo in casa e mi
hanno messo là vicino nello stesso posto
dove io ho visto la sfera nell'84 era
perché a casa mia era venuta questa mia
compagna per controllare cos'era
successo a casa mia da qualsiasi porta
non si riusciva a entrare perché la
porta era bloccata con il chiavistelli
cosa hanno fatto il mio vicino di casa
di sopra gli ha dato una spallata per
rompere la catenella che era inserita
nel chiavistello sono entrati e la la
stanza la casa era esattamente come io
l'avevo lasciata come senza di te chiusa
come hanno vissuto cioè come come stare
con Franco una relazione hanno vissuto
con paura Quella sera lì la mia compagna
perché mi ha cercato di tutte le parti
addirittura sotto il letto dentro gli
armadi Ma lei ti crede e dopo per forza
mi deve credere perché i fatti parlano
da soli e non c'è mai stato un momento
nel quale tutti sei detto oh ma potrebbe
essere che c'è un 5.8 un 5% dove si se
tutti mi dicono ma è assurdo ma è
assurdo assurdo Forse ho sbagliato io
tipo un sogno stavo sognando non è
successo No non ho mai ho sempre avuto
la certezza perché anche i miei amici
che erano così in macchina con me hanno
visto correggere e la mia ex compagna
che ha visto che è uscito di casa senza
aprire le porte cioè con le porte chiuse
dall'interno rispetto a come parli di
questi alieni no fondamentalmente non
c'è niente di male No infatti perché la
segretezza la segretezza la Vogliono
mantenere gli altri non io i governi che
vogliono mantenere Quindi c'è un
complottismo governativo dietro proprio
questa cosa anche perché il sospetto
Anzi quasi la certezza che i governi
conoscono molte più cose di quello che
ci dicono tutti fidi degli alieni non è
che mi fido troppo Cioè però fino adesso
ho dovuto ho potuto fidarmi perché non
mi hanno fatto niente di male e Scusa la
domanda maliziosa per te è più facile
farti iniettare una cosa indicibile non
conosciuta da un alieno che un vaccino
per una pandemia sono lontano il vaccino
Eh me lo devono inventare loro e deve
devono chiedermelo gli alieni me l'hanno
iniettato e basta contro la sua volontà
me l'avessero chiesto però probabilmente
avrei detto di no Ah ah ah ha senso io
mi sento di chiudere però con una cosa
no visto che tu comunque questa
narrativa la porti avanti da tutta la
vita c'è un messaggio che magari non è
emerso che vuoi lasciare a chi ha sta
ascoltando Di non avere paura non
abbiate paura perché quando arrivano
sembra Cioè è una cosa piuttosto paurosa
Non fidatevi perché non c'è niente di
male in quello che vi faranno Perfetto
grazie mille grazie mille grazie Michele
Lollo Allora che dire Io comunque lo
ammiro è convinto come ha detto lui Cioè
Da 40 anni che dice la stessa storia e
continuerà a dirla io sapete cosa penso
che sia più triste di una persona che ha
vissuto e che vive una menzogna
attaccata da tutti una persona che forse
invece sta dicendo una verità ed è
attaccato da tutti Allora io purtroppo
ho un piccolo problema eh Guarda siamo
io spengo ogni volta che comunque si
mette in dubbio Lascia lascia stare io
ho difficoltà un po' a capire
effettivamente quanto poi le cose
diventano fanatismo e quanto le cose
diventano realtà veramente tolto gli
occhiali oggi è vero Prova a fare un
discorso complesso Ora è difficile
empatizzare con un'esperienza che
chiaramente non solo non ho vissuto ma è
per me è complessa anche immaginare con
un racconto che viene fatto in tempo
reale no nonostante questo credo che nel
momento in cui una persona chiede di
avere spazio per la sua verità ho fatica
a riflettere su quanto effettivamente si
Meghi poi Un'altra fetta di verità
scientifica non so se è chiaro come
messaggio quindi lì mi spengo un pochino
però ascoltarlo io torno a casa pieno di
domande di dubbi sono curioso di sapere
quello che in realtà gli ascoltatori
pensano E qual è la grande lezione che
oggi secondo me ci siamo portati a casa
perché non bisogna aver paura è una è
una roba abbastanza aver paura di dire
la propria ma soprattutto non bisogna
aver paura di
ascoltare
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Ok Allora ragazzi e niente tutto molto
bello ma l'orizzonte non so se lo vedete
Ma c'è l'ultima puntata di questo
podcast siamo arrivati alla fine sono un
po' triste però Vabbè ragazzi
hanno inizio alla fine mi segue il naso
dalla tristezza Eh lo vedo quindi non
lasciamoci prendere dalla tristezza però
perché con l'ultima puntata di feroce
abbiamo deciso di chiudere veramente in
bellezza ragazzi avremo come ospite una
persona che abbiamo voluto tantissimo e
che ci permetterà di portare il nostro
viaggio su un altro livello
allacciate le cinture perché con la
prossima puntata puntiamo direttamente
alle stelle
tutto ragazzi e ragazze un graffio
com'era bella Ok grazie mille
[Musica]
[Applauso]